between the passion X and the kazars
is a journey of 10 days through step
lands and forests
there is no main road or beaten track
between them and the chaos there is only
this route through forests and thickets
until they reach the country of the
kazars
the country of the kazars is extensive
on one side is a great mountain chain
and it is the same mountain chain that
slopes down at its far end to to las and
AB cos this mountain chain reaches to
the region of to fleece they have a king
called the Isha and a greater king
called the Kazakh Gong though he has
this name the kazars do not take orders
from him the Isha has the power to
command and the control of the army and
answers to no higher authority their
supreme authority is Jewish and so is
the Isha and those commanding officers
and important men who support him
the rest of them follow a religion like
the religion of the Turks
their city is Sarika shim and nearby is
another city called carne Ballack the
inhabitants dwell in these two cities
during the winter but in the spring they
go out onto the step and stay there
until the onset of winter there are
Muslims in these two cities they have
masks Imams museums and Quran schools
their King the issue imposes a levy of
cavalry on the people of power and
wealth in accordance with their wealth
and means they raid the pechenegs every
year this issue leads the expedition
himself going with his men on raids they
present a handsome spectacle when they
go out in any direction they go out
fully armed with banners lances and
strong coats of mail he rides with ten
thousand horsemen some regular troops
others levied on the wealthy when he
goes in any direction a sort of disc
like a drum is carried in front of him a
horseman bears it before him and he
follows leading the army who can see the
light reflected from the disc when they
take booty it is gathered together in
his camp and the issue takes what he
likes for himself leaving the rest to be
divided among the troops
[Music]
you